holter winkel nein ich hab ich dafür
nicht töten
ich dachte es geht natürlich in
frankfurt schnell wie kommt mein
schreibservice sg zh und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
heute möchte ich mit euch mal was machen
was ich mir gäste ausgedacht habe
relativ spontane idee aber ich glaube
das könnte ich cool werden und zwar
haben wir öfters aus meinem channel
changes gemacht so kleiner mit mir
alleine oder mit anderen youtube und wir
haben auch schon community aktionen
gemacht wie zb zuschauer überrascht und
das würde ich jetzt sehr gerne mal
kombinieren und community challenges
machen also changes mit der community
das könnte glaube ich eine coole sache
werden so haben wir sowieso das sowieso
was eigenes finde ich das echt nice und
heute habe ich mir ausgedacht dass wir
so einer quiz community change machen
die geht so dass ich in runde zwei wie
games gehe aber nur kisten öffnen und
gegner killen darf wenn ich zuvor eine
minecraft frage also eine frage zum
thema minecraft richtig beantwortet habe
das ist die ganze geschichte wie es
aussieht sehen wir als können wir
loslegen aber vor die runde startet
müsst ihr mit drin schon mal eine frage
stellen dann wichtig ist öffnen darf
schnell irgendwann 13 bis 16
nice session ok direkt manstein schwert
die change ist übrigens richtig
schwierig also wir haben gestern schon
auch noch versucht gehabt das war auch
nachts um vier okay aber habe ich nichts
mehr gab also ich konnte nicht mehr
einfach static irgendwelche komischen
zahlen addieren und die sache ist sollte
ich muss das vor jeder kiste machen
hier ist eine frage scheint wie kraft
man wolle aus trinks 4 x 4 strings ich
dachte im inventar
kürbis on ice rollte winkel
nein ich hab ich dafür nicht töten ich
dachte es geht natürlich in frankfurt
schnell wie kommt mein schallplatten
schallplatten in dem 1 1 ein skelett ein
kripperl schießt oder aus welchen
dungeon kisten kann alles okay es dauern
so junger mensch wert aber der hat jetzt
auch nicht so scalise montag kritisch da
habe ich glück gehabt dürfen nicht die
dummen sind
ich weiß nicht nein auf die plattform
gehe ich nicht raus da bin ich safe tot
ok also genau das ist die sache heute
immer wenn ich ein gegner bevor ich den
gegner töten darf oder nicht ist davon
darf darum ist eine dom ist eine schnell
frage für frage wie man einen pisten
pisten unit das ist so eine richtige
export frage was der wieder viele range
hatten hat es gesehen hat da kommt ein
redstone in die mitte nein ich hab sie
den folgen gesehen aber ich habe keine
ahnung hat man die piste gekrabbelt
meinem leben direkt das maximale level
das maximale level 256 blöcke ja junge
westlich davon angreifer zu töten
das okay des downtown ist wunderbar
wunderbar junge you das läuft richtig
gut die zeit ist echt den st perfekt
perfekt ja ich gebe euch bescheid geben
beschied alltag eines gefällt mir
dies ist gut man dies ist wie gut ich
sortiere mental aus machen da vorne
kommt dann irgendwann frage gibt es
schon mal konkurs abbauen
mit einer spitzhacke dort in die
weiterfahrt gewartet hatte man brauche
auf jeden fall schickt hat aber ich kann
spitzer kommissar geht nicht schwert mit
nähe sagen sagt nein auf acht punkte
da warte ich da ich darf ihn töten ich
hab ich noch kein getötet für die
fahrkarten für die statusfrage sehr gut
okay aber wartete wartete dann löst sich
das erstmal ein will ich sagen ich
glaube dass mal ein an hier vielleicht
den baum lehrer ja oder gemüse muss ich
muss ich muss ich muss rein rust
aussteht ausschnitt aus stein herzalter
miese zeiten ok gold apfel heiltrank
dieser verwalter des so schnell in der
mitte gewesen alter krass ich hab mir
die leute sich teilweise tiefe aber kein
problem
ok warten wir müssen jetzt angreifen ich
habe das gefühl dass die schwerter ist
das problem
und er hat mir auch gerade eben böse
kommen gegeben als er wird schon wissen
was er macht so okay jetzt greift die er
nicht akzeptieren
nein ich bin im kopf in den korb
ja ja ja papa papa junge junge alter
schwede junge feierabend alter schwede
was ist hier los
habe ich dann getötet oder nee das war
der andere natürlich muss entscheiden ob
ich den getötet habt dann brauche ich
eine neue frage wo steht kurz gucken
bernarding getötet oder so jetzt habe
ich einen kühlen kurz ein bisschen
futter einpacken so wenig food muss man
ganz gut hin
natürlich jetzt wo ich in folge stellte
bad frauen als erste bank zu machen also
in die weite war okay gut dann ist es
natürlich klar aber man braucht nicht
für jeden trank dort ein sprecher ja
genau man braucht ihn etwas ist es
glaube ich dass du meine aber man
braucht ihn nicht für jeden tag das ok
ok ok egal neue frage 26 sehr schön
jetzt hab ich nen abgespeichert alter
okay das problem ist halt ich habe keine
pfeile ich hab kein essen was ich mir
übergeben kann
und der typ penetriert mich gleich was
ich machen ich muss wo ich schreibe
füttert nein es ist nämlich weg es wird
mich perfekt
nein
rüdiger hahn alter junge der doch
richtig gezogen aber kann man hier nicht
übernehmen ok die runde lief aber echt
gut
die runde lief echt gut nur am ende
hatte ich hatte kein flug mehr
schade aber leute wenn ich die change
gefallen hat das gerne mal daumen nach
oben da und schreibt man die kommentare
ob wir noch eine folge aufnehmen sollen
dann machen wir das gerne
ich würde sagen das war's soweit von
heute mit der ersten folgen community
church haut rein gut und danke ich dir